I want to follow up about this bigger
story through covid that we're seeing of
conservative radio hosts anti-mask
Advocate radio hosts anti-vaxx radio
hosts dying of covid after bashing
vaccines
Business Insider now reports at least
seven conservative radio hosts and
high-profile anti-mask anti-vax
Advocates have died from covid in recent
weeks radio hosts Bob enyart dick
Farrell Phil Valentine and Mark Bernier
as well as former CIA officer and
conspiracy theorist Robert David Steele
anti-masker Caleb Wallace and South
Carolina Republican conservative leader
Presley Stutz
shared conspiracy theories about
theories about vaccines before catching
covid they told supporters
misinformation about the virus they held
rallies in opposition to mask mandates
as coveted cases continue to search
nearly all of the deaths are among the
unvaccinated and misinformation remains
widespread remember all of these stories
we talked about Bob enyart refused to
get vaccinated before dying of covet he
had a show called real science radio he
died Monday
um dick Farrell from Florida radio host
advocated against the vaccine on
Facebook before his death
said the vaccines were bogus said fauci
was a power tripping lying freak he died
of covet
uh Phil Valentine recovered extensively
who actually became a vaccine Advocate
after being hospitalized he didn't make
it Phil Valentine died Mark Bernier
recovered another Florida right-wing
radio host set on air he was against
vaccines I'm not taking it are you
kidding me Mr anti-vax jeepers
he died of covet
former CIA officer Robert David Steele
spread coveted denial conspiracies
throughout the pandemic
he died from covid Over the it looks
like the last weekend in August this is
not fun it's not funny it's it's sad and
uh it's happening to people that listen
to these folks as well Caleb Wallace
Auntie masker who protested covet safety
measures spent a month in the hospital
only 30 years old and died called covid
tyranny called lockdowns and masks
coveted tyranny
uh by the way another important detail
he started showing symptoms in July and
treated himself with Ivermectin
vitamin C zinc aspirin and an inhaler
none of those things shown to actually
work for covet
Presley Stutz
64 year old South Carolina conservative
group leader died after making fun of
masks
chair of the Greenville Tea Party
made false statements about the virus
downplayed the importance of mask
wearing so listen in terms of hierarchy
and reach and audience these are
relatively low level radio people right
I mean they were they seem to have been
true believers they've now paid a price
the larger audience people you know
Hannity Tucker Laura Ingram Glenn Beck
people like that
um they strike me more as being con
artists I think particularly given the
revelations that Fox News is vaccination
and testing program is even stricter
than the one outlined by Joe Biden and
yet Tucker and Laura they keep working
there my sense is that the fox people
aren't really true believers they are
grifters these guys really seemed to be
true believers and you even saw them
change some of them like Phil Valentine
when it started getting really really
bad
um unfortunately even these deaths may
not convince people of stuff if you go
on the right wing enclaves online you
will see people writing these guys were
murdered because they spoke out against
the vaccine
it's an unfalsifiable claim right well
it looks like if you're unvaccinated
you're more at risk and look now these
people died no no no no they were killed
the conspiracy goes because they spoke
out against the vaccine
there is no convincing a lot of these
people but hopefully these deaths are
not completely in vain they are
senseless but they are hopefully not
completely in vain in that some people
will have been convinced to get
vaccinated as a result I don't know if
that's the case let me know your
thoughts you can find me on Twitter at
dpacman one of our sponsors is
curiositystream the only subscription
streaming service that focuses
exclusively on documentaries if you love
documentaries the way I do you're
missing out if you don't have a
subscription to curiosity stream I love
it for one reason it has the biggest
best selection of documentaries that
you'll find anywhere including the
newest popular ones that everybody's
talking about and most of it is stuff
you really can't find on other streaming
services last month they added a ton of
great new documentaries to the library
one I watched is brimstone and Glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in Mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off meaning you
can subscribe for just 15 bucks a year
not a big price tag relative to the
hours and hours of enjoyment I know you
will get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com Pacman the link is
right underneath this video